la radio a récemment franchi le cap des
100 ans d'existence technologies
révolutionnaire à ses tout début ses
premiers balbutiements ont été marqués
par une absence quasi totale de
réglementation jusqu'à ce que les
autorités Ferent le potentiel de
dérapage au Canada ce sont des émissions
diffusées par des radios affiliés à une
organisation religieuse ontarienne qui
poussent le gouvernement fédéral a mieux
encadrer ce média de masse en pleine
ascension un espace de liberté qui mène
à des dérives qui poussent ensuite les
autorités à sévir voilà un scénario qui
vous semble peut-être familier
Pierre Trudel bonjour et bienvenue dans
bonjour très heureux de vous avoir en
personne dans ce studio radio n'est-ce
pas de circonstances pour parler des
débuts de la radio ou et comment vous
voyez un parallèle possible entre
l'arrivée de la radio d'une nouvelle
technologie qu'on veut progressivement
réglementée et l'arrivée d'Internet en
effet il y a des analogies parce que la
radio se développe à l'origine dans un
environnement où on dit c'est une
technologie on peut s'en servir c'est
une technologie qui permet de s'exprimer
mieux s'exprimer plus librement et il y
a un certain enthousiasme une certaine
euphorie de la nouveauté et quand on y
regarde de près c'est tout à fait ce qui
s'est passé avec l'émergence d'Internet
l'ancien internet arrive on a John Perry
Barlow qui lors d'une conférence à Davos
déclarent un texte qui est devenu
célèbre qui s'appelle la déclaration
d'indépendance du super espace dans
lequel il proclame que les États n'ont
pas d'affaires sur l'Internet que c'est
un espace d'intelligence et de liberté
et puis s'il y a des problèmes les
usagers vont régler ça en truc
de l'Internet libres de l'Internet sans
contrainte a marqué considérablement les
débuts de l'Internet et dans ce sens-là
il y en a la logique avec la radio
c'est-à-dire que on les deux
environnements techniques sont perçus au
départ comme étant des environnements de
liberté et qui devrait être affranchies
de toute contrainte et si il y a des
analogies à faire est-ce qu'il y a aussi
des leçons à tirer entre l'émergence de
la radio et ce que ça a présupposé est
l'émergence du web avec tout ce à quoi
on insiste il me semble que une leçon
importante à tirer c'est que lorsqu'on
utilise les technologies aussi
puissantes ça peut avoir des
conséquences
on s'est aperçu au 20e siècle que
l'utilisation de la radio
pouvait donner lieu à des tragédies bon
à l'époque nazi on utilisait la radio à
des fins de propagande
au Rwanda avec la radio des Mille
Collines mais ça a donné lieu
littéralement un génocide c'est à dire
cette utilisation intempestive et
abusive la radio pour propager la haine
ben ça a eu les conséquences absolument
tragiques on a qu'on connaît
il y a des choses auditeurs commencent
pas dire des choses qui sont inondables
le parallèle qu'on peut faire c'est
qu'on se rend compte de plus en plus que
l'Internet aussi est un objet
extrêmement puissant c'est un réseau qui
est extrêmement
performant et qui permet de rejoindre
beaucoup de monde et si on combine avec
les technologies numériques qui
permettent de créer des contenus ça fait
en sorte qu'on a après on est en
présence d'un objet dangereux ou
probablement aussi dangereux peut-être
même plus que pouvait l'être la radio
non contrôlée au 20e siècle lorsque on a
vu à quel point ça a pu donner lieu à
des dérives
si deux technologies aussi différentes
que la radio et l'internet ont connu des
débuts semblables à certains égards
certains de leurs artisans respectifs
ont aussi des points en commun surtout
ceux qui tentent de défier les normes et
les restrictions qui se mettent
progressivement en place
aussi explorer le parallèle qu'on peut
faire entre la parution de la radio la
réglementation puis l'arrivée du web et
la tentative de rendre réglementation
qui s'est produite ou pas par la suite
ça continue d'espérer ouais mais je
trouve ça le parallèle parce que c'est
quasiment en tant quasiment en train de
revivre les mêmes débats en tant que
société puis on voit qu'il y a certaines
personnes là qui ont profité un peu d'un
vide de réglementation là pour s'emparer
de cette technologie là puis de propager
toutes sortes de messages il y en a un
en particulier qui a frappé ton
imaginaire et qui incarne parfaitement
cette possibilité de parallèle entre ces
deux époques oui un personnage qui me
fascine c'est John bringlee
on dirait que son le prenait là puis on
l'amenait aujourd'hui ce gosse serait un
podcaster ou sera un youtubeur on dirait
qu'il on dirait qu'il vient de notre
époque mais lui était dans les débuts de
la radio là dans les années 20 aux
États-Unis un peu un médecin charlatan
il y avait des de médecine est un peu
tout le temps en train de dévader les
autorités aux États-Unis parce qu'il
pratiquaient la médecine illégalement il
y a inventé un traitement farfelu ou il
implantait des morceaux de testicules de
boucle dans des êtres humains disait que
c'était bon pour un peu près toutes les
maladies Imaginales un vrai charlatan
vers le début des années 20 il passe à
licence médicale en Californie mais il
réalise il y a la radio il réalise le
pouvoir de la radio et il crée sa propre
station de radio une station qui
s'applique KFC donc au Canada aux
États-Unis il crie sa station de radio à
sa radio il y a beaucoup il y a de la
musique c'est un des pionniers de la
musique country aux États-Unis il y a
des sketchs il y a des nouvelles de
toutes sortes de choses mais parsemer à
l'intérieur de ça il vend ses produits
dans ses produits ils vend même des
prescriptions pour des traitements qui
ne fonctionnent pas aux Américains bref
il devient extrêmement populaire un
point tel que les autorités aux
États-Unis se disent bon ben on peut
plus laisser ça aller l'ancêtre du FC
ici le Ferro commun
décide de lui révoquer sa licence de
radio au Candice et lui il y a la
brillante idée de pourquoi ne pas
s'installer au Mexique et de
retransmettre à partir du Mexique
exactement donc pour contourner le son
10 plateformes
il va s'installer sur la frontière
américaine avec le Mexique créer une
station au Mexique pointe ses antennes
vers les États-Unis et réussit à
contourner parce que la réglementation
en place aux États-Unis ne couvre bien
sûr pas le Mexique et puis là il réussit
à continuer à atteindre les Américains
en contournant les réglementations en
place le lieu parallèle à faire avec
notre époque aussi tout à fait donc on
sait de nos jours là quand des
personnages un peu problématiques sur
les réseaux sociaux se font par exemple
bannir de Facebook Twitter YouTube ils
vont aller sur d'autres plateformes des
plateformes comme Rambo même le l'ancien
président américain dans notre chambre
sa propre plateforme toutes ces choses
et le ben ils vont publier sur ces
plateformes là sont bannis de twitter
facebook mais les gens font tout
simplement prendre des captures d'écran
vont mettre ça sur les plateformes à
grande déploiement donc ils réussissent
à contourner un peu les contours
d'utilisation des sites web donc on voit
carrément un parallèle avec ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui sa radio était
tellement puissante au Mexique on fait
l'entendre jusqu'au Canada c'était la
radio la plus puissante au monde
certains moments donnés incroyable et
puis là ben comment qu'il s'est rangé
c'est qu'il pouvait pas traverser la
frontière donc il appelait sur une ligne
téléphonique vers le studio au Mexique
et il retransmettait son émission de
radio par téléphone le gouvernement
américain le Congrès américain dit il
faut passer une loi spécifiquement pour
lui le bringley actes pour empêcher les
gens de faire ça de faire des
transmissions radio à l'extérieur du
pays une loi faites sur mesure pour ce
personnage qu'est-ce qu'il fait il
devient un pionnier de la radio pris
enregistré donc il crée des
enregistrements aux États-Unis les
envois à la frontière et finalement
continuer à jouer des enregistrements de
la radio depuis le Mexique aux
États-Unis donc il a réussi à contourner
toutes les réglementations en place aux
États-Unis pendant près de 10 ans ça
[Musique]
de télévision son émission web qui
réussit malgré le fait qu'il est barré
toutes les plateformes à faire circuler
ces messages sur Internet ouais et on
verra justement si à force de contourner
les réglementations comme ça à
répétition bah ça va pas provoquer les
autorités au point d'imposer
déréglementations véritablement
efficaces et musclé